You think you can fix me. Jean you are not broken.
The mind is a fragile thing. Takes only the slightest tap to tip it in the wrong direction.
Charles,
What did you do? I had to keep her stable.
I protected her.
From the truth?
There's another word for that.
I came looking for answers.
You feel like you don't belong here. You don't.
They can't begin to comprehend what you are.
She's changing. Into what?
You didn't come here looking for answers. You came here looking for permission.
Jean.
She's all rage.
Pain. This will be coming after us.
Jean lost control, but she's still our friend. This is your fault, Charles.
The world is on the brink. I'm sorry. I didn't stop it sooner.
You're always sorry, Charles. And there's always a speech. And nobody cares.
There's still hope.
Don't do this.
They're right to fear me. I've seen evil.
And I'm looking at it now.
Hey everybody, we finally got the official Dark Phoenix trailer. It's time to break it down
You probably recognized a whole bunch of stuff there from the comics or from x-men the animated series
But I'll try to explain what's going on. Especially with the main villain being played by Jessica Chastain
There's a new round of that spider-man ps4 giveaway
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment on the video
What it seems like based on the footage is as they're doing the Dark Phoenix saga from the comics - some of the Shiar empire
Space-based story, so I don't think that Jessica Chastain is playing lilandra
Like I initially suspected when they first cast her the Shiar Empire part of the story was such a big part of all the previous
retellings of the comic book stories
So it was just kind of taken on faith that they would incorporate that but this seems a little more grounded more about Jean
Versus the x-men her hurting all of her friends, which is a big part of that comic book story
So you start out with the flash back to her initially coming to the x-men
They said you could help me and it sounds like based on his
Conversation with mystique Professor X messed with jeans mind so that she wouldn't remember
Accidentally killing her family when her powers manifested the whole thing with the Jean Grey. Is that even without the Phoenix force?
She's an omega-level mutant so she was powerful before she was ever infused with that. You see later in the trailer
They go into outer space. That's when she's hit with the Phoenix force
They make a very fantastic four type of cosmic radiation description
Like she's hit with a mysterious force of energy while they're in outer space
That's the Phoenix force jumping into her body you see her infused with it
But you kind of got a taste for that during x-men apocalypse
So I don't know how they're gonna explain them going into outer space in relative continuity because you see them wearing these new x-men
Uniforms from the comics and timeline for x-men apocalypse wouldn't totally make sense if they do this
She turned into the Phoenix then they went into outer space
So we'll just have to wait for more footage to explain the timeline, but the way they posed this here
It's like you see beasts examining her and then later you see him with Magneto and the other people from Genosha. That's right
They're doing the island of Genosha. It looks kind of like a hippie commune right now
Like he's just created it and it's meant to take the place of the Hellfire club in the comics
So I'll explain that in a second, but you see beast with her here
he probably
Sympathizes with her then sort of jumps sides when he finds out what Professor X is planning on doing
To subdue her later in the timeline when she gets really crazy
So they're doing a little bit of x-men schism in addition to Jean Grey going full Phoenix and hurting some of her friends
I love the look on Magneto's face when she walks up. He's like, what the hell? What are you doing here?
He probably realizes how powerful she is then later in the trailer when she starts to go super dark
You see her start destroying those military helicopters
Probably because she just wanted to protect everyone here and just sort of gave in to the darkness within her like earlier in the trailer
Professor X is talking about how a balanced mind can swing one way or the other just depending on triggers
So we'll see what the actual thing that triggers her is
But it might just be the military coming to Genosha gunning people down the whole thing with Jessica Chastain's character
Is that a lot of people think that she might be a female gender bent mister sinister as in Miss sinister?
He's done that in the past in the comics, and she's the sort of stand in for the Hellfire Club
The whole thing in the comics. Is that Emma Frost in the Hellfire Club?
Wanted to co-opt Jean Grey and turned her evil
So eventually they were able to mess with her mind for a little while at least Jean Grey became the black queen of the Hellfire
Club so this could be that version but I don't know that the Hellfire Club itself is an actual part of the movie
So this could just be say mrs. Sinister or a different version of Emma Frost
Just trying to twist Jean Grey evil for her own
Purposes her to tell if this is before or after Jean Grey goes to Genosha because she's wearing the same jacket
But this might be when she does something
Really messed out the x-men try to stop her and she thinks that there's nothing to be done about it
So she just wants to go off into the wilderness and hang out on this island where she doesn't think that she can hurt anybody
Then you have that slow montage of her just completely losing her shit in the x-men slowly
breaking apart because of what's going on like you can understand that Professor X does something to mess with her mind to prevent her from
going full Phoenix
So not all the x-men are on board for that like beast here seems like he's at odds
Which is probably why he's standing with magneto later in the trailer this shot of him inside, sir, bro
Getting the full psychic blast of the Phoenix force is him
Probably trying to figure out what happened to Jean on the spacecraft like when she was hit with that special radiation
They're examining her inside the medical Bay. This is him. Probably trying to do the instant replay inside her mind
So he looks inside her and all he sees is just fire reaching out at him
Obviously they're playing that cover of the doors
This is the end and then you see them standing over that grave
One of the other x-men probably gets killed
Accidentally by something that Jean Grey does and that's what causes her to want to leave to go to Genosha
Totally digging all these shots of Magneto if you haven't seen it
There were some behind the scenes pictures of him playing chess with Professor X
It's just a reference to them beginning the chess game that they played during the Patrick Stewart Ian McKellen x-men movies
This shot of her is probably about as close as we get to her with full Phoenix force
But obviously it's gonna look a little crazier because you look at these mock-up shots that they released earlier this year
This is what she look like when the Phoenix has fully taken over her mind
So it'll be interesting to see how they conclude this because the comic book version was Jean Grey
Realizing that the only way to save everyone was to kill herself
So because if you guys didn't know this is like the swan song for Fox x-men movies before they go back to Marvel
So I don't know how they're gonna try and bookend all the Fox x-men films or if this is going to be more
Self-contained but the fact that they use that door song
This is the end is important for the Phoenix storyline
But also in a really meta way for the x-men characters at Fox in the movies like this is the end for Fox's x-men
Movies let me know in the comments. What do you guys think of this?
Obviously, it looks way more grounded than the comic book version or even from the 90s animated series
They did Dark Phoenix saga in five episodes
So I don't know where that's streaming, but you can actually probably go find that right now
So the movies coming out at the beginning of February
meaning that we'll probably get a whole bunch more footage before the end of the year and we can try to figure out a little
Bit more about what's going on with their timeline and who Jessica Chastain is playing exactly the real seabass. Congratulations
You're the giveaway winner from my last big video
Please email me on the about page of my channel so I can get your details
Click here to learn all about brand new Ironman armor during Avengers 4 and click here to learn all about
Black costume during spider-man far from home. Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay. Awesome. I'll see you guys tonight